so no big changes of the last 24 hours
in terms of the areas that russia
occupies in ukraine highlighted here of
course in red though there was a fresh
attack last night to the west lev in
particular
and the airport there the part of the
airport which is used to repair military
aircraft and alex that feels like it
must have been a targeted attack was it
and how did they achieve it from so far
from their own territory it definitely
feels like it was a targeted attack most
probably done with a cruise missile
cruise missiles have a range of up to
many thousands of kilometers so it's
perfectly plausible that an attack could
have come from the black sea or from the
russian landmass itself
cruise missiles are very specific in
their targets so it's unlikely that this
was an accidental strike and more likely
designed to hit critical national
infrastructure and also a warning to the
nato allies that russia can reach almost
to the border of the nato alliance you
mentioned uh that nato alliance and the
word accidental in there 45 miles from
lev to poland where nato troops
including british troops are to be
stationed is there a chance of an
accident happening there was 45 miles
far enough there's always a chance of an
accident but it really does seem
particularly if it was a cruise missile
which can be targeted for a precise um
attack pot like a window um that that it
was it was a sign to show the west what
russia is capable of
let's uh move from the west to the east
and the donbass region in particular we
also learned last night that russia is
trying to establish a no-fly zone in the
donbass region alex is that easy for
them to achieve with the equipment that
they have and is it necessary because
they've occupied that region really
since 2014. i think this is really a
sort of propaganda move on the part of
the russians it's a sign that they're
looking to their audience that they are
being proactive because neither ukraine
nor russia has full control of russia of
ukraine airspace and so therefore it
isn't really a feasible move to suggest
but it will play very well back in the
heartlands if we look over the last
couple of days of this
war it seems now like mario pole is the
epicenter still of course in uh
ukrainian hands
for now despite very heavy shelling
could it fall relatively soon and if it
did would it change the narrative alex
of the russian success so far from one
of strategic failure to one of strategic
success
mariopol is a city of some 400 000
people so it is subject to at the moment
indiscriminate bombardment
so it could fall
in the context that the city will be
pulverized we're we're clearly seeing
that the russians are going beyond
strategic targeting to just widespread
destruction and devastation
if it falls it provides russia with a
clear route by land from the russian
mainland to the crimean peninsula and
the strategic m17 road
but this will really this is a tiny
corner of a very big ukraine so i'm sure
it would play very well in moscow that
this was a great victory uh but for
ukraine we must not forget that there is
there is a lot more country still in
ukrainian hands dr alex warmsley thank
you so much